- I'm Tyler, I'm a stripper
with the Hollywood Men.
- Hi, my name is Egypt Blaque Knyle,
and I am known as The
Golden Girl of Burlesque.
- It just kinda happened so fast.
I went buck wild.
I got super excited.
So many girls there.
- I ran into a couple of guys that I went
to high school with,
and to see those guys who
are older than me in there,
it was a very horrifying experience,
but after that it was wonderful.
They went into a bag of mine
and seen all the G-strings
and the bikinis,
and it was actually my
grandfather who noticed
because he washed everything in the house.
He asked me, what are you doing?
My family has always been supportive.
- I actually called them and I didn't know
exactly the reaction to say,
I'm going with the Hollywood Men to dance,
waiting for the reaction,
and my family totally supported it.
They ask once every other show at least.
I thank them for the offer
but say I don't do that.
- I get propositions for
sex by men and women.
It really doesn't bother me.
It really comes with the territory.
I handle them by saying no.
- They ran out of money so I
got offered chicken tenders,
and I said, thank you but I'm good,
and they went to the ATM machine,
I came back, and I also
ate the chicken tenders.
They were actually really good.
- I had another male
exotic dancer say to me,
I wanna drink your bath water
even after you pee in it.
Who said I pee in my bath water?
I don't get aroused in an orgasmic way.
My arousal is more of
a mental type arousal.
I call it the mind fuck.
- There's always those special few girls
that get me going to say the least.
So every night I get aroused, absolutely.
I will never refuse to dance for anybody
that smells bad or looks bad ever.
The only time I'll refuse is
if they go too much touching
or if they're just too drunk.
- I have refused to dance for
a guy and a woman, actually,
because their hygiene wasn't up to par.
Looks no, I don't care what you look like.
The most that I have ever made made
probably was about eight or $9,000
and it was a birthday night.
- The most I ever got
in one night was 3.5K.
It was awesome.
It is difficult to be in a
relationship for most people.
We like that connection and our
interaction with the ladies,
but it is still a job
and sometimes the significant
other doesn't realize
that we know that.
- You know, the only
think that I hate is when
people try to change you.
Either you're with me or you're not,
and majority of the time
they think they're with me,
and then after a while,
they're not in it anymore.
- It's about how you take the clothes off,
not just take your clothes off.
- The stigma I don't think
it sticks with everyone.
If you're an individual and
you have morals and values
and you grew up a certain way,
you won't follow the leader,
you will be the leader.
Teaching in a pose studio
I notice a lot of women who are older.
You should see the way they release
and they enjoy their sexuality,
and they become sexy and
they didn't even know
they had all this sexiness.
If people will open up
and stop being so stuffy
and stop judging and being judgmental
about stripping or whatever it is in life,
I think we can overcome anything.
- End of the day who
cares what people think.
If you like it, go do it.
(lighthearted music)